[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Please welcome to
Google, Miss Sarah Williams
Goldhagen.
[APPLAUSE]
SARAH WILLIAMS
GOLDHAGEN: Thank you.
I'm really excited to be here.
Really excited to be at Detroit.
There's a part of me
that feels like I'm
preaching to the converted
because you guys know
the built environment matters.
It's been changing
a lot here and so.
Nonetheless, even
those people who do
know that the built
environment matters,
don't necessarily know
all the ways it matters
or why it matters.
And there are plenty of people--
all you have to do is look at
most of the American landscape
and you know there are plenty
of people who don't think
it matters very much at all.
So I wrote this book
because I really
needed to explain
to a wider audience
why they should care about
design and about architecture.
And it took me through
a whole journey
into environmental psychology
and cognitive neuroscience,
and frankly, fields
that I really
didn't have that much
exposure to until I
started working on the book.
And I ended up, I
think, making the best
case I could for how to think
about the built environment.
And how to think about
approaching, designing
it, and making it better.
So what this talk
today focuses on really
is kind of conceptual reframings
of how to think about the built
environment, and then I
show you some projects
that actually embody and use
some of the design principles
that I came up with
that are really
central to people's experiences
of the built environment.
Why is this up, you may wonder.
We're looking at nature.
This is the first
conceptual reframing
I want to encourage which
is, it was only really
50 or 75 years ago when I
was a kid, not 75 years ago,
that when people
thought of nature,
they thought of rivers,
and mountains, and forests,
and fields, and
disaggregated elements.
Rivers had their
own biological logic
and forests had
theirs, for example.
But then, as people figured
out the polluting effects
of automobiles, the unintended
but toxic secondary effects
on animals of pesticides,
and so on, this eventually
led to a paradigm shift.
And people began to reframe
how they thought about nature,
conceptualizing it as a single,
multifaceted, and profoundly
interconnected phenomenon which
they called the environment--
so from nature to
the environment.
And then following that
reframing as the environment,
the environment became a terrain
of social and political debate
leading to all sorts
of policy initiatives
in public health
and social justice,
environmental protection,
and now, of course,
around climate change.
So the way people once
thought about nature,
before the environmental
revolution, which really
started in the
1960s, quite closely
resembles the way most
people think about the built
environment today.
There are buildings.
Buildings are created
by architects.
There's parks and
public squares designed
by landscape architects.
There's infrastructure,
bridges, roads, et cetera.
Those are designed
by civil engineers.
And then there's
streetscapes like these.
This is Greenwich
Village on your right
and Louisville,
Kentucky on your left.
Streetscapes and
these kinds of things
are the [? professional ?]
province of urban designers
and city planners
who, all too often,
work with their hands tied
behind their backs, frankly.
But even though this is the
way both the marketplace
and professional disciplines
parcel out the built
environment, it's wrong.
It's wrong because that's not
how people experience built
environments.
For people, the
built environment
as we experience it, is one
continuous, interrelated,
integrated entity where what
we see outside the building
through the window is
as important as what
we're experiencing
inside the building.
So this monolithic
tower that you
see on the left, which is by a
highly respected architecture
firm, REX, looms
pretty forebodingly
over the streetscape to
which it's connected,
and which it bridges
over, and it looms also
over the little landscape
park that's on the left.
And the small four-story
vernacular buildings.
My husband, when he
looked at this slide,
he said you mean the schmutz?
On the right.
So people need to think
about the built environment--
the way that people think
about the built environment
needs a paradigm shift.
Just as in the 1960s
and '70s, nature
was reconceptualized
not as a panoply
of desegregated elements, but as
a single integrated [? hull. ?]
We need not to think about
architecture, buildings,
civil engineers, city
planning, and so on,
but a continuous
built environment,
and that is where the
vast majority of people
all over the world spend
well over 90% of their lives.
And it's designed, all of it.
There are decisions and each
part of the built environment
is a series of
decisions that could
have been made differently.
It's critical.
So today, new
scientific findings
are streaming in from a lot
of disparate disciplines,
most importantly from
cognitive neuroscience
and from environmental
psychology,
revealing a lot about
how people actually
experience built environments,
both as individuals
and in social groups.
And all these
findings and research
suggests that many of
the ways that people
think about the
built environment
also needs to be
reconceptualized.
People tend to act as
though the environments
that we occupy, that we
work in, that we live in,
and so on, they tend to
think of it as like a stage.
And our lives are like
these little mini dramas
that take place on this stage.
And what you're focused on
is the drama of your life.
You're not focused on the stage,
the stage is just a platform.
Not true.
What's emerging is that the
built environment is not
neutral at all like a stage.
It plays an active
role in many dimensions
of human internal and
social experience.
For example, who knew
that the buildings
we inhabit profoundly
affect our health.
And more generally,
how we feel physically.
Or that the environments we
inhabit affect what and how,
as well as how well we think.
That's kind of amazing.
Indeed, what's emerging
clearly indicates
that the built
environment's effects on us
are far, far greater
than anyone, even
architects, appreciate.
So take the example--
and that's what you
see on the slides--
of how built environments
affect our physical health.
There was a study
in the early 1970s,
and then there have
been a lot of studies
that have followed
off of this one, that
showed that after patients
had gallbladder surgery,
they were released from the
hospital 30% more quickly
and suffered about 30% less
pain if they happened to land
in a recovery room that had a
view of a pastoral landscape
rather than a recovery room
across the hall that looked out
on a brick wall.
30% quicker, that's a full day
earlier these patients were
discharged, 30% fewer
requests for pain medication
along the way.
That's a big impact.
So one of the places in the
built environment that's
already beginning to
incorporate some of this work
is in the health care industry.
In spite of the fact that a
lot of the hospitals and stuff
aren't that great,
they're getting better.
They're already having an
impact on the health care
architecture.
On your left, for example,
is the Nanaimo Emergency
Department on Vancouver
Island where the architects--
so it's an emergency room.
The architects basically
parceled out the emergency room
which was like for 60 or 70
beds, something like that,
into these little
pods of spaces.
And then, each little pod of
space got dropped with a light
well into the center and a
little garden in the lightwell.
So you lie in bed
as you're in the ER
and you're looking
out on a garden.
How amazing is that?
You think every ER department
should be like this.
They get natural light.
They get a little green.
But natural light can
ameliorate some forms
of mental illness such as
depression, that's well-known.
And, of course,
whether or not a room
receives natural
light, whether it's
in your home or your
workplace or with other,
depends on how the
building is designed.
As well as where you are in the
corporate hierarchy, I guess.
But our knowledge of light's
effects on mental health
is becoming so fine grained,
it's really so fascinating,
that now we know that people
suffering from bipolar disorder
recover from a mania much
more quickly if they happen
to land in a room, if
they're in-patients,
that receives a lot
of morning light,
rather than a room that receives
a lot of afternoon light.
Same amount of light,
but morning light
has a bigger effect on
reducing the symptoms of mania
more quickly.
So there's study after
study of this kind of stuff
of the effects of
our environments,
the physical
environments on health.
But health's not the only thing.
The built environment
affects us not only
in these kind of very
quantifiable, physical, health
ways, it affects us in
all sorts of ways that
are really quite surprising.
We now know from
cognitive neuroscience
that most of what we think
is actually nonconscious.
And I use the word nonconscious
rather than unconscious
because I don't want anybody
to ask me about Freud.
Nonconscious.
But also, I use the
word "nonconscious"
because consciousness is
really on a spectrum where
nonconscious is over here and
hyperconscious is over there.
And things move-- can
move along that spectrum.
That being said, most of
what we think, most of what
we process at any given moment
is about 90% nonconscious.
That's big.
And most of the nonconscious
schemas and associations
that people deploy to rapidly
process their environments
and their daily experiences
in and about the world,
originates in the
blunt fact that humans
live in the kind of
bodies that they do.
And they experience the
world and the things in it
according to conceptual
categories that are
derived from their embodiment.
Our cognitions are
profoundly influenced,
they're even structured by the
fact of our human embodiment,
of living in bodies.
What does that mean
that my thoughts are
structured by my embodiment?
It's kind of abstract?
Let's take a metaphor
that everybody
knows which is
thinking inside the box
or thinking outside the box.
We intuitively
understood that metaphor
because we know
what it feels like
or we can imagine what it
feels like to be inside a box.
It's kind of confined.
It doesn't allow for a whole a
lot of movement or flexibility
or whatever.
And we also know what it feels
like to emerge out of a box.
It's kind of liberated.
And I like this example
a lot because there
was a psychological study
where the researchers actually
constructed like a 10
by 10 by 10 foot box
and they put people
inside of it with a desk
and they gave them a test.
And they said, take this test.
And what the
subjects didn't know
is that they were
measuring creativity.
So they took the test.
Went away.
Two weeks later, they came back.
Same box.
They said sit outside
this box and take a test.
A different version of the
same test measuring creativity.
Well, lo and behold, people who
were sitting outside the box
scored consistently higher
on measures of creativity
than people who were
sitting inside the box.
So that's like a metaphor
that we understand
because we live in bodies
and we occupy containers,
and so on, in the world.
It's part of this
larger picture of what
we're calling embodied
cognition and the schemas
that we use to understand
our experiences.
And that's just
one example of how
the environments we
inhabit affect the ways we
think because of
our nonconscious
and embodied associations
that we bring to them.
So another example
about cognition.
I think this is really cool.
It makes me think I should
have gone to college
in a different place.
It's been shown that students
who take exams in rooms
with ceilings that
are painted sky blue
score higher than when they
take exams in rooms that are not
painted sky blue, with ceilings
that are not painted sky blue.
And more generally,
people who work or learn
in environments
with high ceilings
consistently score better
on tests of creativity
than when they are in
environments with low ceilings.
So all of this stuff is like--
that's why I'm saying yes,
we get that the built
environment is important,
but the ways--
who knew all of these ways?
Emotions, that's one that
maybe people intuitively
get more quickly.
It's like you know that
you walk into a dump
and you feel a little dumpy.
So the fact that the
built environments,
the environments we inhabit,
influence our emotions
is maybe less surprising.
We look at a bright
yellow staircase
with a wood-- this is actually
a hospital that was built
in the 1920s on your left.
And the architect consciously
painted the stairs
this sunny, brilliant yellow.
And he also-- this was at the
point that architects were
really fascinated with metal--
and so he put a metal
banister on there,
but he said nobody
wants to touch metal.
Metal's gross to touch.
It's always cold.
It transmits too much--
it collects the air
around it too quickly.
So he put a wooden banister on.
And he was right.
You look at a sunny
staircase and you
imagine touching a warm banister
that's made out of wood,
and it feels like a better
space than the other.
Now this is one that
I particularly love,
this example, which is
this is the interior
of the cathedral at
[? Amyah ?] in France.
And if you haven't seen
it, you should go see it.
But you can imagine
other spaces that you've
been in where you just
walk in to go, wow!
Unbelievable.
So think of that experience,
standing in a cathedral
or whatever place
really awed you and you
thought was incredible.
In [? Amyah, ?] you
can't help but feel
this wonderful
admixture of emotions.
You're personally small and
a little bit overwhelmed.
While at the same time,
you're spiritually
uplifted because you have this
glorious creation surrounding
you.
And scientists have
demonstrated that when
people feel that feeling
of awe, that feeling itself
nudges them towards what are
called pro-social thoughts,
to consider their individual
place in a larger community
and in a larger cosmos,
which in turn gets
them thinking about their shared
humanity with other people.
So places that inspire awe,
what Burke in the 18th century
called the sublime,
demonstrably help people
feel connected to one another.
Who knew?
It isn't an exaggeration
to say that built
environments and specifically,
the design of built
environments, affect how
people fare physically.
They affect how they think,
decide, interact with others,
as well as how they
feel emotionally.
What we now know is that
these effects are real
and they're not negligible.
So what this suggests
is a second reframing.
The first was from architecture,
landscape architecture,
to the built environment.
The second reframing that
I think we need to do
is instead of talking about
the mind/body connection which
we hear about all the time,
it's the mind/body/environment
connection.
That's what we need
to be thinking about
because we're humans.
We live in habitats and
those habitats profoundly
shape what we think,
how we feel, what we do,
and how we communicate
with others.
Another logical
implication of this
is that there's
another way we need
to rethink the way that
most people currently
think about buildings as well
as landscapes and cityscapes.
Today in the media and
in professional practice,
the built environment is
typically bifurcated in two.
There's architecture
on the one hand.
Obviously, the building
on the right up above.
Fancy forms, kind of cool.
You can imagine being there.
Wow, that would be great.
This is by Zaha Hadid.
It's in Azerbaijan.
So architecture
typically describes
very expensive objects
that are constructed
at the behest of elite clients.
And then, there's
everything else.
That's Detroit,
by the way, which
looks more typically
like what you see here.
Not architecture,
but just building
or even just construction.
In these parts of the
environment, which
is most of the
built environment,
design and quality construction
is much less highly prized,
if it's prized at all.
Most of what exists in
our built environments
is not really designed,
it's just built.
But what we know
now and are learning
about the built environment's
profound but mostly
nonconscious effects on how
we think and feel and so on,
suggests that even the most
elementary and simple projects
would serve people
better if they were more
thoughtfully designed and
more carefully constructed
using the knowledge that we
now have about human cognition
and experience.
There's no split between
architecture and building.
It's all architecture
and it all matters.
And when it comes to
the built environment,
there's no such
thing as neutral.
If a building or a streetscape
or an urban plaza or green area
isn't helping you,
chances are it's not
doing good things to you.
I can't say it's
literally hurting you.
In some cases, it certainly
is, but they're not neutral.
None of it is neutral.
So we need to start thinking
about the built environment
as is it enriching us or is it
impoverishing our experience?
And I use the word "enriching"
for a specific reason.
It also comes from science.
And there's abundant
scientific evidence
that when people inhabit
enriching environments that
engage them motorically,
that give them
a lot of different
things to do, that
give them a lot of different
ways to imagine themselves--
I'll explain more about
this in a minute--
they literally
grow better brains.
They have dendrites
with more branches.
A higher density and complexity
of synaptic connections.
So what does all of
this mean in terms
of what should be done
differently in terms of design?
Compare this playground,
which is Stavanger, Norway,
to the ordinary
playground that you
take your kid to when you don't
have time to go anywhere else.
Among this thing
that this new way
of thinking about
human experiences
and embodied
cognition tells us is
that the way a place
looks to our eyes
is only a very
small part of what
makes it an enriched or
enriching environment.
Now, I'm going to step
back for a minute.
If you think of cognition
the way that most people--
what I call the folk
model of cognition--
the way most people think about
thinking or analyze thinking.
You think, I get all
the sensory input,
and it comes from all these
different sensory portals.
And then, I process it, and I
use my memories and experience
of other places.
And then it becomes
an experience.
It turns out, that's really
not how we understand
the places that we are.
It's a much more complex process
that involves not just vision,
although our brain
does privilege vision,
but auditory stimulation
is incredibly important.
Tactile stimulation is
incredibly important.
And, in fact, one of
the things I really love
is that you don't
need to actually touch
surfaces to have them
activate your tactile sensory
perceptions.
All you need to
do is look at them
and you imagine what it
feels like to touch them.
So surfaces and
textures and colors
are really, really important
in ways that, I think,
have not really been recognized.
The other new
finding is that our
built environmental cognitions
are not only multi-sensory,
so looking at a surface
actually activates
neurons in our brain
associated with vision.
That's multi-sensory.
It's not only
multi-sensory, but what also
is called multi-modal
which means
that sensory perception is
always preparation for action.
Your motor neurons are involved
So I look at that
window and I imagine,
could that window open?
Does it open that way?
Does it open this
way or whatever?
Or I imagine sitting
on the chair.
Is it hard?
Is it soft?
Our motor systems
are involved when
we're in the built environment.
So in terms of this
playground, that's
why just looking at
all those orange balls
can inspire in us a sense
of playful buoyancy.
Because you think, wow, bouncing
on those balls, that'd be cool.
So enriched
environments give people
many, many different kinds of
opportunities to engage in them
and to imagine engaging in them,
even if they don't actually
engage in them.
And they stimulate not just
our visual system, but also
our sense of touch,
hearing, movement, and more.
So you look at this
surface here and you
can imagine what it feels like
to walk on top of that surface.
And this playground,
which, by the way,
I think is incredibly
cool, uses these old--
everything here is recycled
materials, by the way.
It has sound components so
that you can bounce sound off
and then you can hear
it like 30 feet away
on the other side
of the playground.
It's full of a
lot of cool stuff.
So this is the moment when I've
given such, yay, design matters
talks that someone
goes wait at minute.
Isn't that really expensive?
We can't always
afford to do that.
In fact, I was giving a lecture
in rural Arkansas at one point
and I gave my little spiel.
And hand shoots up right
afterwards and says,
we're building a
post office in town.
Now that's a public
building, which
means it has to be functional
and it has to be inexpensive,
so what can you tell me about
design for that building?
So I wrote a whole book
to try and answer that.
As I said, there isn't a
divide between architecture
and building, it's
all architecture.
And if you have a tight
budget, don't the services
of a designer just add costs?
Not necessarily and
not if done well.
At pretty much any
level of investment,
you can purchase better
design or worse design.
Put in another way--
and this actually sort of went
around Twitter the other day--
it cost just as much money
to design a bad building
as it does a good one.
And so the examples
that I'm going
to show you that embody
some of the principles I've
been talking about
are where there
has been virtually no budget
or a teeny, tiny budget.
And the people have done
extraordinary things.
What you're seeing
on the screen is
in Port Elizabeth, South
Africa in one of the townships.
It's a daycare
center and community
center that is built entirely
of recycled and scavenged
materials.
So we have corrugated
plastic, wooden pallets,
discarded lumber, discarded
tires, and scavenged bottles.
It's a one room building with
the community constructed
under the supervision of a
bunch of volunteer architects,
basically.
So I showed the
picture on the left
just to show you
that's the setting.
That's what everything
else around it
looks like is these
corrugated, tin, little huts.
But the designers managed
through really simple means
to convey a sense of place
that dignifies the community
and dignifies the people
who use it so have a look.
One principle they used--
let me just describe this.
So these are just alternating
pieces of lumber--
one placed this way,
one placed that way.
That's it.
Not that hard to do.
These are the ends
of the bottles that
were scavenged to
create this thing which
is, as you can see on the
inside, a whole window a wall.
The designers first
use the principle
of patterned complexity.
Humans are nothing if not
pattern-seeking creatures.
That helps us comprehend our
environments really quickly
and with minimal effort.
We're always looking to
see what the pattern is.
Patterns also reassure people
by giving them a sense of order.
So I know I'm in a
controlled environment--
there's a pattern here--
and gives coherence to
a project of any scale.
But we all know that
patterns on a large scale,
even on a medium
scale, a pattern
that lacks sufficient
complexity is boring.
You see that a lot in
the built environment.
That's part of the reason so
many people dislike modernism,
but we won't go there.
So in this building,
complexity is
created by the unexpected use
of these scavenged and recycled
bottles to create this
incredibly luminous,
wonderful wall.
There's multi-modal stimulation.
In other words,
stimulation of our motor
as well as our visual
and sensory neurons
because we look at that wall
and we can imagine, particularly
on the inside, you can
imagine what it feels
like to hold onto that bottle.
You've held on to
bottles like that.
You've imagined what it's
like to have one in your hand.
So it stimulates our imagination
and our motor neurons,
our tactile engagement
with these services,
even if we never touch them.
The bottles also,
obviously, introduce color
and fill the interior with
a kind of diffused light.
Remember, light is really
bright in South Africa.
And that light
changes all day long
and this really simple, one
room interior as the sun
moves through the sky.
So other details that I love.
The windows are opened by this
very simple pulley system.
So you think, open a window,
imagine just doing the pulley.
It's easy.
And they really had no
money, these architects,
so they wanted to
create sliding doors
so they could open it
out to the community.
So what they did was
they got old skateboards
and they used the wheels
in the skateboards
to create the runners
to slide the doors.
So that does two things.
When you think wow, a
skateboard, that's a door.
So it's a creative
transformation
that carries some of the
meaning of the former use
of that object, the
skateboard, into and creates
a kind of sense of playfulness.
So you might say, well,
that's South Africa.
The United States is a
bit more complicated.
Well, no, it's really not.
In fact, the lecture that
I was giving in Arkansas
was the same time I
saw this building.
So this is rural Arkansas--
house here, little
shed-y thing here.
And I want you to focus on
that building right there.
That's a Russian Orthodox
Church in Springdale, Arkansas.
It's in as vernacular
detritus-filled landscape
as you could possibly imagine.
So the congregation
for this church
had no money, certainly not
enough to build a new building.
So they settled for a three-car
garage, which they bought.
And they hired a
local architect named
[? Marlon ?] Blackwell to
redesign it and make it
into a church.
So Blackwell used very
simple, very inexpensive
materials, basically
Home Depot kind of stuff
like this box metal facade.
But he took the principles
of human pattern seeking
and people's proclivity
to be drawn to landscapes
of patterned
complexity, and he also
used color, which I'll
talk about in a minute,
to create an absolute
jewel of a building.
He wrapped the entire
facade in this sturdy box
corrugated metal and lined every
edge, windows, top, bottom,
and so on, in black
to create a crisp.
This is a constructed building.
All you need really
is that black edge
and you go oh,
wait, that doesn't
look like every other corrugated
metal facade building I see.
He also floated it--
you can't really see
it in the image--
but these are all blackstones.
And so he stopped
the corrugated metal
about that far off the ground
and then, poured blackstones so
that makes the building
appear to float.
It's a church.
So it just creates a
little bit of specialness.
And then he placed the windows--
one, two, three
and then, I'll talk
about the cross in a second--
in really unexpected locations.
So to break this
repetitive striated pattern
in a way that captures our
attention go oh, well, wait,
what is that?
And then you have the
suggestion of the cross.
He glazed the windows with
different colored glass, red,
blue, yellow, and so on
in this tiny building--
it's a tiny building--
to create a different
emotional atmosphere wherever
you are in the building.
He also-- what you're seeing
on the top left hand side,
and he used to paint so
colored glass and paint.
So in this image,
that's the cross that
has red colored glass on it.
And then from this
tower, he just
basically painted it
with this red paint
to create this incredibly
red luminous interior.
He mostly edited out your views
of the surrounding landscape
because we saw what the
surrounding landscape looks,
like not exactly
something that makes
you feel spiritually
uplifted, but it gives you
views of the sky.
So it's such a smart design.
So you proceed from
the front entrance,
which is over here, along
the short hallway which,
during services, has candles lit
as they do in Russian Orthodox
faith.
So you're already getting
prepared for the mood.
Then you stand in
this light-filled,
red-filled space as the
transitional moment--
this is a small hallway
we're talking about--
before you enter into
the sanctuary space.
And that is, by the
way, natural light
that is slotted in through
a skylight at the end.
But you don't know where
the light is coming from,
creates a sense of mystery.
So we have craftsmanship.
We have the use of color.
We have a very carefully
sequenced spatial procession.
We have a relationship
of interior
to exterior that's very
thoughtfully managed.
Pattern complexity.
And all of this comes
together to create this really
distinctive, peaceful place.
Now this is one of my favorite
parts of this little church.
So it's a Russian
Orthodox congregation.
They really wanted a dome.
They didn't have money to
build the dome, not even a cent
to build the dome.
So what did Blackwell do?
He found an old
discarded satellite dish
and he struck it in
the ceiling and he had
someone paint a painting on it.
So does good design
have to cost money?
No.
And the other thing
the satellite dish does
is that it reflects
the sound back
and so it improves the acoustics
of the space quite a lot, too.
So my parting words, the
design of the built environment
is no discretionary luxury.
It's central to human
well-being, to human health,
to cognitive development,
and to social relations.
It's not just architecture
versus building landscape
architecture versus voids.
Our built environments
are habitats,
and it all can be better
designed or worse designed.
And so this is the
last way we need
to change how we think
about the built environment.
Instead of asking, as so
many architecture critics
or other people or
laypeople do, do I like it?
Is it to my taste?
Is it any good?
You can ask all those
questions, that's fine,
but we also need to be asking a
different set of questions that
are actually more
important, which
is, where and with what
means can we create
more enriching environments?
And how?
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: Thank you, Sarah.
I'm going to kick things off.
I have a quick question
and then, obviously,
if we have any
audience questions,
we can flip over
to that as well.
In your book, which I
read-- which is fantastic,
by the way--
you say that much of our built
world can and has to be remade.
We have before us an
unprecedented opportunity
to reshape the world
into a better place.
And, again, we talked
at lunch beforehand,
one of the reasons we wanted
you to come to Detroit
was to talk a little bit
about the city of Detroit
because we do have a fantastic
opportunity to really rebuild
a city that people
actually live in,
kind of from scratch almost.
What's your advice for
a city like Detroit
to take some of the principles
that you discussed previously
in the presentation S
apply it to this rebuilding
and revitalization of a
giant metropolitan area?
SARAH WILLIAMS GOLDHAGEN:
A few things, one,
they should read my book,
but more important-- well,
that's important, but don't be
seduced by this architecture
versus building divide.
Don't think so if we invest
in these big iconic things,
then that'll help and
attract attention to so on.
Big iconic things are fine.
I have no problem with
big iconic things,
but investing in design at
all levels is important.
But it's not just that, I'm
not saying that architects
are heroes because
a lot of architects
are not really trained
in the principles
that I'm laying out here and
that I lay out in the book.
Because of
postmodernism, because
of a whole lot of
different things,
basically, the mantra
among architects
is you can't really
predict people's experience
of an environment.
We don't know enough.
It's all subjective.
French people experience it
differently from Americans.
No.
There's a lot we know.
And that knowledge should
become much more widespread,
and should be
incorporated into what
clients expect from the
designers that they hire.
And that means
looking to fields that
are not necessarily directly
connected to architecture
like environmental
psychology and so on.
And there are architecture
firms that are actually
putting environmental
psychologists,
and cognitive scientists,
and so on on staff.
So get the right stuff,
that would be my advice.
SPEAKER 1: One
other question, too.
You focus a lot on
education in the book
and you mentioned it in
the presentation as well,
how it relates to
performance and creativity
and things like that.
I find it interesting, you've
got on one end of the scale
when children are
very young, you
go into most modern
daycares or kindergartens,
and there's lots
of natural light.
There's lots of
soft, round surfaces.
Some of that for
safety, of course.
But lots of bright
primary colors.
Lots of fun, interactive,
creative things
that these children
could play with.
And kids obviously
develop and it
seems like a really fun place.
I've got two children.
I go to their daycare, and
I'm automatically happy.
As you progress through
your educational career,
you go into colleges,
most universities,
you go into a big
lecture hall, and it's
cream colored,
white, hard chairs,
very boring, very
non-traditional in terms
of a place of
education and learning.
How does that happen?
How do we go from getting
it so right at a young age
to completely losing
this vision of design
and the built environment
when it comes to colleges?
I know that there's
history there,
a lot of these universities
were built 100 years ago,
if not longer, but there's
still a lot of modern buildings
that we're building, especially
in the educational field, that
have these same issues.
How do we bridge that gap?
Where did we lose sight
of that design process?
SARAH WILLIAMS GOLDHAGEN:
Well, I made a reference
before to modernism.
I said this is why
a lot of people
hate modernism because
it's so repetitive.
Most of the stuff that
I'm talking about,
people just didn't know
15 years ago, a lot of it.
And so most of those spaces
were built with the neutral,
the environment as stage
set-- the built environment
as stage set model where the
environments themselves weren't
going to help people learn.
But we know that's not true.
And actually, I think
you may be referring
to one example I gave in a book
which is actually a study done
on college students
where they put college
students in a typical
classroom with linoleum
floors, and hard metal
desks, and some blackboard,
and stuff like that.
And they seated them
in a circle and so on.
So they-- I don't know.
I can't remember the
details of the study,
but it was something like
they did two weeks of class
in that classroom.
And then, they did another two
weeks in a similar classroom
in terms of size and orientation
and arrangement of furniture.
But the furniture was soft.
And there were
rugs on the floor.
And there were task lights.
And there was a
couch behind them.
And the students participated
something astonishingly,
like 40% more and
were more engaged
and therefore learn
more in what was
the so-called soft classroom
than in the hard classroom.
People just don't know.
They don't know
these things matter.
And part of the reason
that people don't really
appreciate the build
environment so much
is because most of our
thoughts are nonconscious
and the built environment
is inert and static,
and so you don't pay a
lot of attention to it,
but that doesn't mean
it's not affecting you.
SPEAKER 1: Have you
seen any studies
that show how
people develop maybe
in more of a city versus a
suburb versus the country?
Or I'm sure there's no average
American city or suburb
or country, so to speak,
but in the same way
that you're talking about how
certain buildings are designed,
have you expanded it more
on a macro level and just
to kind of understand how
people develop in those three
types of environments?
SARAH WILLIAMS
GOLDHAGEN: Oh, sure.
Absolutely.
I tend to emphasize it
less because, particularly
the suburb versus city, is a
pretty well-known comparison.
Suburbs are very isolating,
and they're very homogeneous.
And cities are like
beehives of diversity.
They're different people and
there's different things to do.
So you tend, in a suburb, to
get a very homogenized view
of your social world.
And also, there are times--
I wouldn't say this
to my husband--
but there are times when I
think the nuclear family is
about the worst thing that
modern society has given us.
There are other times
when I think it's great.
But kids that grow up with
more than two role models,
if you hate your dad, you
like your uncle or stuff
where they're just more
people around and more
internet communities--
we know this-- are
psychologically much
healthier kids.
So there's definitely a big
urban dimension to this.
So much so, the configuration
of the streetscape
can either encourage people
to connect with one another.
To look at each other.
Or to put their eyes down and
just look at the sidewalk.
There's a ream of stuff
out there about this.
AUDIENCE: Sarah,
thanks for the talk.
Really interesting stuff.
I have not read your book, but
I do have a question for you.
It seems as though--
my understanding of
one of the hurdles
to getting great
design more ubiquitous,
whether it's in the
United States or globally,
is this understanding
of the value gap.
And I think the way
I would describe
it is that the economic
costs are easily understood,
and they're written
in economic terms,
and they're easy to
measure, essentially.
And then the value
component to great design
is often talked about in
terms of enrichment and things
that are not
economically defined.
Do you have any
examples, whether be they
public or private
projects, where
folks have done a really
good job of economically
defining the value proposition
of doing greater design?
SARAH WILLIAMS GOLDHAGEN:
Absolutely, yes.
Post-occupancy evaluation
is what it's called,
and it's something that
architects are still
having trouble with
because it kind of holds
them accountable
in ways they wish
they weren't held accountable.
But there are
post-occupancy evaluations.
I can think of two.
One is a retail
supermarket in which
they were in a big boxy type
space, no natural light.
And then they moved into
a different building
that had skylights, and 25%
to 35% more customers, a lot.
A lot of studies have been
done on workplace productivity,
including by people who had been
working on this for a long time
and really know what they're
doing so the studies are
excellent, in which
they show that employee
retention, workplace
productivity, all these things
have been measured.
They go up dramatically in
better designed environments.
So those are two
examples I can think of.
There are others, too.
There was-- actually,
it was in Michigan.
It was a factory in Michigan
that they hired an architect
who does a lot of green stuff.
And he did a little bit like
that emergency department.
He put these little
green moments
all through the building.
And, again,
productivity went up.
People were happier.
They stayed at the jobs
longer, et cetera, et cetera.
So there are coming to be
more and more examples,
and we need lot more
studies of that.
SPEAKER 1: Well, hopefully
we see an evolution occurring
right now and, again,
we hope Detroit
is a landscape for a lot of
folks to come in and practice
some of these design
efforts and expand upon some
of the opportunity available.
Thank you, again, Sarah.
This was very interesting.
We really appreciate it.
Congratulations on the new book.
Thank you, again, for joining
us for Talks at Google.
One more quick
round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
SARAH WILLIAMS
GOLDHAGEN: Thank you.